logo dollars ces touristes latino
américain venu de californie ont
traversé le continent dans un but bien
précis visiter des sanctuaires nationaux
de l'église catholique
après un arrêt à sainte anne de beaupré
à québec il ya notre dame du cap à trois
rivières les voici maintenant à
l'oratoire saint joseph à montréal
concerne la ville à vélo sans selle mais
il a commencé comme olivier comment
comment feront ils s'entraînent dans ces
établissements est ce que c'est
important il ya le pèlerinage est aussi
leur façon de se rapprocher de dieu mais
là il y a quatre ans on ne comptait
qu'une centaine de pèlerins venus de
tous les coins du monde
aujourd'hui ils sont plus de 2000 a
demandé à cette année aux autres sein du
canada d'intercéder en leur faveur
normalement les pèlerins seront plus en
europe via un climat d'insécurité qu'il
faut qui fait en sorte qu' il ya un rock
et aussi vers le canada je pense que le
taux de change par rapport à la
clientèle américaine fait en sorte qu'
il ya un développement un accroissement
de la clientèle américaine
ça me fais aider à user les oeuvres
pontificales missionnaires se
réjouissent que leur promotion à
l'étranger des sanctuaires québécois
portent fruit c'est ce qui est en hausse
actuelle au québec actuellement à
continuer d'être porte ouverte est
d'offrir un magnifique pastorale
d'accueil et de célébration de la fois
ému par tant de beauté
les touristes sont comblés et parle déjà
de revenir d'ici là ils rapporteront de
nombreux souvenirs au grand bonheur de
la fabrique ici valérie michaela bayne
radio canada montréal